longtime pawn star fans were shocked to
find out that Adam Harrison Rick
Harrison's second son died at 39 due to
a reported overdose following the tragic
news the owner of the world famous Gold
and Silver Pawn Shop took to social
media he wrote you will always be in my
heart I love you Adam due to Adam's
distance from his father's series even
the most stalwart Pawn Stars fan may not
have been overly familiar with him while
he was involved with the business when
he was younger he eventually left it
behind and reportedly began working at a
plumber in 2012 Adam's brother Corey
explained his brother's absence to the
huff post stressing that viewers would
probably not see Adam in front of the
cameras Cory claimed quote he's a
plumber now when pressed if he thought
Adam might be a little jealous of his
older brother's growing Pawn Stars Fame
Cory appeared to reply with some
light-hearted banter he said I think
there has to be some type of jealousy
Cory Harrison at 40 years of age was a
mere year older than his brother Cory
like his father also took to Instagram
to remember his younger sibling the
heartfelt post features Cory holding a
photograph of him and his brother as
children playing in a bathtub underneath
the caption reads wax WTF I will always
love you Bubba as a whole the Harrison
family has asked for privacy during this
tragic ordeal they said in a public
statement our family is extremely
saddened by the death of Adam we ask for
privacy as we grieve his loss along with
the Harrison family longtime Pawn Stars
viewers and celebrities alike continue
to reel from Adam's shocking and sudden
passing with countless condolences is
constantly pouring in currently Cory
continues to work with his father on the
show Jake Harrison Rick's third son
first appeared on the show in 20121
though he's rarely been in the spotlight
since in 2022 Rick shared on Instagram
that Jake was on his way to college
after graduating high school as longtime
fans likely know Rick's Father Richard
Benjamin Harrison famously known as the
appraiser and the old man passed away in
2018 at 77 due to Parkinson's debuting
in 2009 Pawn Stars remains a steadfast
power house for the History Channel even
in the streaming age the Las Vegas based
series continues to boast Stellar
ratings and maintains an incredibly
large and loyal fan base in 2023 the
series finished its 21st season in the
season debut viewers were treated to the
site of Rick and Chumley trying to tame
the power of gry school as they
negotiated over a classic Battlecat toy
other season highlights include WWE star
Booker T helping the world famous Gold
and Silver Pawn Shop crew authenticate a
pair of old wrestling boots in some
dramatic fashion the season concludes
with Rick and Chum traveling to Belgium
to learn more about a particular
painting specifically how much it's
worth it's currently unknown when the
next season of Pawn Stars will be
released the series usually has new
episodes hitting the airwaves every year
however it remains to be seen if Adam
Harrison's tragic passing affects the
show's production longtime fans will
more than understand if Rick and Corey
Harrison need a break from the cameras
if you or anyone you know needs help
with addiction issues help is available
visit the Substance Abuse and Mental
Health Services Administration website
or contact ca's National helpline at 1
18006624357
[Music]